un des partis pris du projet était de
regarder autre chose que ce qu'on nous
montre des ouragans dont les journaux
télévisés
on voulait explorer comment la nature
réagi face à ces tempêtes
elle vit avec depuis des milliers
d'années donc forcément des espèces se
sont adaptés pour son vivant cette
réflexion nous a amenés dans les forêts
tropicales vente au ricoh affiner les
crevettes des chauves souris les arbres
les serpents dont il se concentre pas
toujours évident mais ça fait partie de
notre travail et nos villages d'avoir le
vertige
photo
sèmassi s'était coupé
[Musique]
les boîtes et travaux allez on y va
ça pue
[Musique]
ce magnifique sens je suis allez c'est
bon ça c'est bon c'est magnifique quand
il a un des plus gros défis sur ce film
techniquement était de construire un
ring sous marin 3d et donc on a fait les
premiers tests en piscine avec des
questions traditionnelles qu'on a
assemblé pour voir comment réagissent et
le relief est le miroir sous l'eau
deux ans plus tard on a réussi à
fabriquer
donc ce prototype de questions sous
marin qui mettait les deux caméras
dedans avec le miroir et un dôme où le
relief était vraiment ajustable
parfaitement
il ya un dialogue n'a pas suivi entre
les deux cas mais grâce à ça on a pu
avec une seule personne puisque souvent
ces règles a été très lourd avant il
fallait plus des grues et beaucoup de
monde pour mettre à l'eau là où une
seule personne pouvait le manipule sous
l'eau et on pouvait le mettre à l'eau
très facilement être contact des animaux
et de la nature est évidemment allé
tourner au plus fort de lowell ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]